when you're a sinner file you get used
to disappointment after all Hollywood
can't deliver the goods
all the time sure infinity war was
pretty great but we've still got Justice
League to deal with Hunger Games might
have torn it up at the box office but
divergent couldn't quite make it to the
finish line
Jurassic Park to find blockbuster cinema
for a generation its sequel The Lost
world at Jurassic Park not so much
that's how it's been forever and yet it
still stings when a film fails to meet
our expectations especially when that
means bundling a scene that we've waited
years sometimes decades to see unfold on
the big screen he is not so fond look
back at movie moments that Hollywood
failed to deliver the Phoenix rises and
falls when Jean Grey gave her life at
the end of x2 x-men United sacrificing
herself to save her teammates x-men fans
knew what was coming and he couldn't
wait after all the Dark Phoenix saga is
considered one of the best x-men
storylines of all time well Fox and
Brett Ratner didn't get the memo
in the comics Jean Grey realizes that
the only way to keep the universe safe
from the dark Phoenix's power is by
ending her own life and yes it's just as
heartbreaking as it sounds in x-men The
Last Stand that that's how things go at
all
instead of using Cyclops as an emotional
anchor Jean ends his life on screen
early in the film in the comics the Dark
Phoenix wreaks havoc across space in The
Last Stand as she kind of just well
stands around looking moody when she
kicks the bucket
it's Wolverine who does the deed not
Gina self robbing the former Marvel Girl
of both her agency and a most heroic
moment it started tragically inevitable
ending it's a huge waste of audience's
time and money a stark reality Iron Man
aka Tony Stark makes up for a lack of
memorable minor bodies by butting heads
of one uh turley evil arch-nemesis his
name is the Mandarin and he's bad news
with a bunch of magic rings like
granting special abilities he's a real
thorn in Starks side in the comics at
least while the Mandarin was originally
slated to appear in Iron Man numero uno
he was written out of the movie shortly
before filming in order to streamline
the plot that's why all show heads
biggest fans were excited when Iron Man
3 rolled around that it looked like Tony
Stark's number one bad guy was going to
make his long-awaited debut surprise
that's not what happened at all instead
stark learns a Ben Kingsley's Mandarin
is just an actor playing a part
tall fans weren't pleased in fact the
backlash was so intense the Marvel
apologized by releasing a short film
that reveals the real Mandarin is still
out there that guy though he still
hasn't showed up on screen a Shia left
and scoured he has a fun bit of literary
trivia the Lord of the Rings saga
doesn't end with Sol runs two feet in
the return of the Kings penultimate
chapter the scouring of the shire Frodo
Sam merry and pippin returned home two
bands of NER duels roaming the streets
and machines belching black smoke into
the sky after realizing this was the
handiwork of disgraced Wizard Saruman
Frodo and his friends have no choice but
to fight back and it is badass
unfortunately Peter Jackson's big-screen
adaptation ignores the scouring of the
shire action-packed ending instead it
relegates the whole event to a brief
vision that Frodo sees when he looks
into the mirror of Galadriel okay let's
be real the scouring of the shire isn't
exactly a crowd-pleaser but it's an
important part of the story without Syd
The Return of the King ends on a
tiresome string of happy endings oh well
at least Saruman got his just desserts
and the deleted scenes cursed cameos
it's easy to forget these days with the
parts the Caribbean franchise focusing
heavily on Johnny Depp's wacky Jack
Sparrow for Orlando Bloom's Will Turner
was once the lead character of the
flicks as time went on however his
character became less and less important
to the Pirates franchise in fact he
didn't appear in on Stranger Tides the
fourth entry in the series at all so as
you can imagine Pirates fans were
rightfully excited to see blooms big
return in the franchise's fifth
installment dead men tell no tales then
they saw the movie as it turns out -
blooms role is little more than a
glorified cameo he appears at the
beginning to introduce some MacGuffin
and then returns at the end for a brief
conclusion the real heavy lifting is
done by Brenton Thwaites who plays turn
the Sun and Depp who will keep making
these things as long as Disney keeps
paying him it was a major disappointment
still bloom fed better than Knightley
well she's got a cameo in the film as
well she doesn't get a single line of
dialogue first care taken together the
two Kill Bill movies running for 247
minutes you know how long it takes a
bride to actually end bills life 24
seconds that's air it takes more than 11
times up for the bride to whack Vernita
green the first
victim on her revenge tour Daryl
Hannah's Elvis for over five minutes
before the bride plucks her other eye
outs the fight against Iran each yeast
accuser enforces at the house of blue
leaves goes on for nearly seven minutes
and it takes just under five to Porto
Ren town for GERD basically kill Bill's
entire hookers it's kinetic
hyper-stylized and lengthy action scenes
and yet when it comes to the most
important one-on-one battle in the story
the one that both films are named after
it's over in the blink of an eye as far
as the flicks characters and themes go
it's a fine ending that demonstrates
surprised conflicted relationship with
bill viewers who wanted the movie to end
with a fight worthy of the series
however couldn't help but want a little
more later vada asked any Star Wars
fanatic and they'll set the scene for
you Anakin burned alive lies on the
operating table he's betrayed the Jedi
Order
and driven away both his lover and his
closest friend he has nothing left
slowly the operation proceeds and young
Skywalker has transformed into the
devious Darth Vader broken both
physically and mentally
Vader asked about Padme his fate the
Emperor tells Vader that she has passed
on and worse that Vader himself was
responsible furious the newly crowned
Sith Lord breaks free from his
restraints stumbles forward like a drunk
Panther raises his arms to the sky and
screams and just like that all the
tension leaks out this is arguably the
most important moment in the prequel
trilogy if not the entire franchise and
for some reason George Lucas decided to
make his tragic villain react like a
spoiled child nah turn again thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]